Film Courage: Harvey, when you get a call
from someone to take on a project or consider
a project, what are some of the first things
you do to make sure you want to commit?
Harvey Mason, Jr.: First of all, I look and
see if I have kind of the bandwidth to do
it, the scheduling and it’s something I
can fit into my workload.
And then, more importantly, I look at it from
the standpoint of is it something that is
going to be really, really good, high quality,
something that I am going to have fun doing,
something that I am not going to be coming
into the studio everyday thinking “Oh God,
what am I working on?”
In this point in my career, I want to do great
things.
I want to do projects that I am proud of and
that I enjoy creating.
Film Courage: Definitely with SING movie,
I can see why you would want to take that
project on.
Harvey Mason, Jr.: SING was a no-brainer for
me because it was so much great music, it
was working with an amazing cast and one of
my favorite director/studio head combinations
that I’ve ever worked with, Chris Meledandri
and Garth Jennings.
Those guys are just amazing.
I always love working with Mike Knobloch at
Universal because he’s a real musical guy
and when he calls me with a project, usually
it’s something exciting.
He’s really intense about music and he loves
it.
When he calls and says “Hey I’ve got a
potential project” I stop what I am doing
and concentrate on what he’s talking about
because it’s usually something fun.
Straight Outta Compton I did for him, the
James Brown film GET ON UP I did for him and
so just real music intensive projects.
Film Courage: In another interview you did
with Jennifer Hudson for SING, you two talked
about how some of the music is much older
and a millennials unfortunately may not know
some of these artists, so I think that is
great that you are bringing these older artists
into the movie.
Harvey Mason, Jr.: That has been my goal with
some of this music is to freshen it up a little
bit so that young people can enjoy listening
to it.
Maybe it will make them go back and listen
to some of the music that this artist has
done before.
It introduces it in ways they can digest.
Film Courage: Going back to something you
said earlier about wanting to enjoy what you
are working on, I know you are at a point
in your career where you can probably be choosey.
This is certainly an excellent place to be.
What is it about a project or how do you decide
“You know what, I think maybe this won’t
be for me?”
Was this always the case for you?
Were you always at a place where you thought
“I don’t want to work on this because
I won’t be committed 100%” Harvey Mason,
Jr.: (Laughs) No, I wasn’t always at that
place because I used to commit to everything
100% and it got really draining and tiring,
taxing my creativity.
For years and years, we were doing records
with artists that were not great artists or
artists that you might not think would come
out.
A lot of them didn’t come out.
We wasted a lot of really good material and
songs on artists that we really shouldn’t
have been working on.
But at the early stages of my career, I just
wanted to create.
I wanted to be in the studio.
I wanted to be working on my craft, so I used
a lot of years doing things that I otherwise
wouldn’t have done.
I think it is all a progression.
It goes in stages.
One thing leads to another and gets me to
where I am.
I worked with artists that were new.
I didn’t know if they would come out, but
it ended up that I worked with one of them
and it was Chris Brown, who was 14-years-old
when I started with him.
At that time we were doing a ton of artists
for Jai Records.
A lot of them were new or unsigned.
At that time you never know what is going
to hit, what is not going to hit and he [Chris
Brown] ended up being a kind of a career artist
for me and somebody that I have done tons
of songs with.
So early in my career I definitely took the
approach of work with everybody, give it your
all, pour everything you have into every project.
Now (as you’ve said) I’m a little more
selective and I concentrate on stuff that
I think is going to be great.
Film Courage: I think you started out with
jingles in the beginning?
Harvey Mason, Jr.: I did.
Film Courage: Let’s suppose for someone
starting out, whether it is in music producing,
film, acting, whatever – should they take
on every project that they can at first, but
then once you get to a certain level, choose
which ones are going to fulfill you instead
of drain you?
Harvey Mason, Jr.: Absolutely.
And I would say no project is too small.
You can learn from every project.
You can improve from every project.
You can also build your name and reputation
from every project.
Early on in your career, I would recommend
anyone in the arts be it acting, creating,
anything…start with doing everything you
can.
Get your hands on any project because you
can always improve, you can always get better,
you can always build your reputation and your
name.
You don’t know who is going to hear that
song you wrote for that horrible artist and
then it leads you to a great artist.
And also, you don’t know what you’re going
to pick up from any given session, any given
artist.
You can learn one of the things that can last
you an entire career.
I learned so many things early in my studio
sessions that have stayed with me forever,
all the way to this point to where I do what
I do now.
A lot of what I do now I learned early on
in my career, so that’s a formative time
in your creative process.
I don’t think at that point you can afford
to be choosy.
I see a lot of people doing that like “Oh,
I’m not going to work on that” and I think
that’s a huge mistake.
Because there is always some tiny nugget you
are going to get from everyday you show up
to work in the studio.
It’s repetition…you have to do it hundreds
and hundreds of songs to get to that place
where you are creating great ones.